[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday June 20
and we are on our way to Indianapolis I
would look at you but I'm driving a
gigantic moving van
hey we made it a Indianapolis although
as you will probably notice puff levels
are a little bit high I hope this is the
worst ever look on brother at 2.0 how am
I gonna meet Judy Blume with this hair
hey hey you know it's fun driving a 24
foot moving truck halfway across the
country it's particularly fun when it's
raining because then you don't just feel
like you're steering a runaway train you
feel like you're steering a runaway
train that's on skis also you know it's
really really long Pennsylvania hey hey
congratulations on the Weather Channel I
haven't even seen it yet but mom says
it's awesome so it ended up taking like
18 hours but eventually we made it to
Indianapolis I'm really happy I'm here
look Hank nature I mean you know when I
was in New York it was almost impossible
to contribute to the global water crisis
but here it's really easy
the worldwide water shortage crisis is
all my fault
okay quick question Hank what do we do
about all this grass I mean I used like
eight Bad's worth of water in like ten
minutes trying to make it less brown
Hank I haven't even seen your video from
yesterday so I'm gonna go to Starbucks
upload this watch yours and then take a
nap that's gonna last like 30 hours I'll
see you tomorrow
PS hey Hank I don't even know if you
know this but we were sort of like
halfway featured on YouTube last week
and one of our videos I think it was the
one from June 4th ended up getting a lot
of comments from youtubers and let me
tell you Hank youtubers are smart all
I'm gonna say is that these youtubers
were definitely not nerdfighters hey
speaking of which Hank what's the
opposite of a nerdfighter anyway Hank I
would read some of those comments to you
but unfortunately most of them do not
contain any English words whatsoever
it's just sort of a random string of
letters with an occasional profanity but
one youtuber did write a legible comment
he said I notice you are a nerd
why why why am i inert why
Hank nerdfighters why are we nerds and
why are we proud to be nerds by the way
any nerdfighters who are also youtubers
can go to YouTube and give the video
from June 4th a high rating and it might
be featured again